you know the Department of Justice is an
utterly rotten and compromised agency uh
I know I've been throwing a lot of stink
on them but look I mean this is this is
the agency that gave Jeffrey Epstein a
slap on the wrist they caught the most
prolific child molester in the history
of this country and gave him a slap on
the wrist um and the plea agreement that
they reached with him the the
non-prosecution agreement is one of the
most corrupt documents that I have ever
seen in my life
um and and they handed that out you know
uh
why because well he just knows a bunch
of famous people and some of them were
on his plane to uh uh his his private
island so so can you redeem an agency
like that I'm not sure